this leader is provided to permit the
projection us to complete adjustment of
focus and sound level before the film
begins
elastic tissue abnormalities in the
blood vessels of patients with Marfan's
disease predisposed these patients to
the formation of aneurysms these
aneurysms may be found in a variety of
forms and locations and dissecting
processes involving the ascending aorta
are not unusual this 30 year old man was
admitted to the hospital with a history
of severe substernal pain radiating
through to the back and down into the
lumbar region one and a half years prior
to admission this was followed by
transient numbness and weakness in the
right leg but these symptoms subsided
spontaneously over the next several days
three weeks prior to admission he again
experienced an episode of severe
substernal pain with radiation to the
back roentgen a graphic examination of
the chest demonstrated enlargement of
his ascending aorta examination revealed
the patient to be six feet eight inches
in height with long slender hands
fingers feet and toes in both legs there
was wide separation between the anterior
tibial tubercle and the inferior border
of the patella characteristic of
Marfan's disease no abnormalities were
noted in either eye the heart was
slightly enlarged to percussion and an
early grade to decrescendo diastolic
murmur was heard at the base with
radiation toward the apex the blood
pressure was 120 over 60 millimeters of
mercury in both arms and all peripheral
pulses were present and of a water
hammer characteristic intravenous
contrast visualization of the thoracic
aorta demonstrated aneurysmal dilatation
of almost the entire ascending portion
the transverse and descending portions
of the thoracic aorta did not appear
unusual
there was no roentgen a graphic evidence
of a double density characteristic of a
dissecting process under general
endotracheal anesthesia a median
sternotomy incision was made
the sternum was split with a lambskin
knife
the pericardium was opened
longitudinally
as the sternum was spread the aneurysmal
process was seen to extend from the
aortic valve annulus to just proximal to
the innominate artery
this drawing illustrates the extent of
aneurysmal involvement cardiopulmonary
bypass was instituted employing a
disposable plastic oxygenator primed
with 5% dextrose in distilled water
under normal thermic conditions the vena
kv-- were drained by gravity into the
pump oxygenator and a sump in the left
ventricular apex allowed for a left
heart decompression oxygenated blood was
returned to the femoral artery through a
roller pump and cannula were used to
profuse the coronary arteries during the
proximal anastomosis
claps were placed across the aorta
between the aneurism and the innominate
artery the aorta was divided between the
clamps
the distal cut end of the aorta was
freed up to the innominate artery and re
clamped a small septum representing the
distal portion of the dissecting process
was excised a woven crimped Dacron graft
of the appropriate size was selected and
anastomose to the distal cut end of the
aorta employing an over and over--
suture of 300 linear polyethylene as
demonstrated in this drawing while the
distal anastomosis was performed the
coronary arteries were profused through
the aneurism itself from coronary sinus
blood oxygenated by intermittent
inflation of the lungs and by bronchial
artery returned to the left side of the
heart over distension of the left heart
during the maneuver was prevented by
intermittent decompression through the
sump in the left ventricular apex
[Music]
upon completion of the distal
anastomosis a vascular clamp was placed
across the graft and the integrity of
the anastomosis was tested the left
ventricular sump was used to evacuate
the aneurysm and the aneurysm was
entered the double walls of the true and
false lumen were seen with a tear in the
inner wall just above the aortic valve
annulus the cusps of the aortic valve
were relatively normal a Orting valvular
insufficiency resulted from prolapse of
the cusps into the ventricle secondary
to prolapse of their attachments to the
inner wall
[Music]
this prolapse of the cusps in relation
to their normal position is demonstrated
in this illustration coronary cannula
were inserted and coronary perfusion was
begun
[Music]
a major portion of the aneurysm was
excised leaving part of the outer wall
for future support of the graft
[Music]
the graph was pulled down and cut to
length
[Music]
the proximal anastomosis was begun
posterior Li and such a manner as to
pull the inner wall with its attachment
to the aortic valve cusps back into
normal position during the performance
of the anastomosis
[Music]
this anastomosis was also performed with
an over and over suture a 3o linear
polyethylene incorporating both the
inner and outer walls of the aorta
obliterating the false lumen as the
prolapsed cusps were pulled back from
within the ventricle
[Music]
as the anastomosis neared completion the
right coronary cannula was removed but
the left coronary cannula was left in
place as long as possible in this manner
excellent cardiac contractions were
maintained
immediately prior to completion of the
proximal anastomosis the tourniquet on
the superior vena cava was released and
the left heart decompression was stopped
temporarily to allow the heart to fill
with blood prior to tying this suture
the clamp on the distal aorta was
released briefly in order to allow the
graph to fill in a retrograde fashion
evacuating air from the graft
finally the proximal anastomosis was
completed and the clamp was removed from
the distal a Auto thus up in the left
ventricular apex was used to evacuate
any air remaining in the ventricle
following which it was removed
[Music]
the completed operation is demonstrated
in this drawing with a graft extending
from the aortic valve annulus to the
level of the innominate artery the outer
wall of the aneurysm was cut to size the
proximal anastomosis was wrapped with
surgical hemostatic gauze and the
remaining portion of the outer wall of
the aneurysm was used to further support
the graft the sternum was closed with
interrupted wire sutures the chest was
closed in layers the patient's course
following operation was uneventful
retrograde contrast visualization of the
thoracic aorta was performed two weeks
following operation and demonstrated
satisfactory function of the graft
without evidence of aortic valve Euler
insufficiency the patient was discharged
three days later with a blood pressure
of 120 over 75 millimeters of mercury in
both arms and has remained asymptomatic